a non-profit helping cater a
Thanksgiving meal for residents living
in their building the group provides
low-income housing for Veterans the
homeless and seniors who are on a fixed
income helping them get back on their
feet Joshua peguero spoke to the
organizer who are in need of donations
as you can see here people are enjoying
a free Thanksgiving Day meal but this is
only made possible due to the generosity
of no donors who came through at the
last minute want to drink or anything
sir tells me people care people care
Jim Malone sits on the board of
directors of Hebron and expressed
gratitude for the donation uh what we're
doing here at Hebron is helping build a
transition a bridge from homelessness
into stability Happy Thanksgiving
yeah Hebron is located near Las Vegas
Boulevard and provides low-income
housing
the non-profit Caridad took over the
building a year ago and is a vision of
Meredith spriggs's mission to humanize
the homeless we do a once a month family
meal and I think that's important to
restore people back into the community
especially after they've just come in
off the streets they're kind of missing
that I thought that was the karma play
around 100 people live at Hebron 40 of
them are veterans places homeless
veterans and those who are experiencing
homelessness into job programs Spriggs
says hevron serves as a refuge in the
desert for the homeless and some of
these people have no family so this is
everything for them and it gets them out
of their rooms you know and so they're
not just lonely and alone on the
holidays some of the residents we spoke
to were grateful for the food which
included all the fixings of a
Thanksgiving meal I want to thank them
for everything they have done to try to
get people back up on their feets where
they were supposed to be at here at
Hebron they're still taking donations to
repair a broken boiler pump reporting in
Las Vegas 8 News Now